-Hey it's your buddy, Zach!
-And it's your boy, Sam.
We're here at the Teen Choice Awards blue carpet.
-BuzzFeed sent us to make a video
But, we don't care about that
we're just going to try to get as many selfies
with celebrities as possible.
-All of them. -All of them.
Do you take selfies?
Yeah man. I take a lot of selfies.
-Too many.
I take like 1000 selfies.
It's disgusting.
We're trying to figure out how take amazing selfies
on the blue carpet right now.
You know what?
We're gonna have to figure this out together, because I got a problem too.
So for me. You would have to get on this side.
Ok. Great. Done. Easy.
I'm just gonna sneak right in here.
It's all about the face obviously.
You can't go straight on. You have to pick a side.
And lift your chin a little bit.
Victoria, what's our face?
Are we gonna look cute or hard?
-Uh.
Excuse me?
Have it like...
What's going on?
Hold on.
We need to kind of face the sun a little bit.
Look at that. He's turning around.
He's figuring this out.
-And then you want to just like find your light.
Like your inner light?
Or, like, the actual light?
Both.
It's so bright. How do you look into the sun?
Do you want to close your eyes and I'll count to three?
Yeah. Ready?
Open them on three.
One.
Two.
Three.
(grunt)
(Laughter)
Smile like you're dead inside.
We're having a good time.
-Oh. -Prude.
Oh we're doing kissy face?
Ok, so.
Snoopy!
Want to come take a selfie with us?
Snoopay!
-You're the center of attention.
Love it. Love it.
Just be cute.
-Like, cute or tough?
-Yeah.
-You gotta look tough.
I never smile.
Smiling is so not fun.
Smiling is for happy people.
Just confused. Like what?
Yeah.
Pensive.
What am I gonna eat for dinner?
-Did my mom pack my lunch today?
I hope so.
Do you cheek bones. Bite your jaw.
Maybe like a happy, like...
What do you mean you're biting your jaw?
So, you clench your jaw
And it, like, makes your cheek bones
That is a pro-tip.
You have to turn your head a little bit.
The key is
you see, when you smile
people look awkward
when they smile
you make a weird face.
Nailed it. I would 'double-tap'.
I usually only take 4.
Options.
Love it, love it.
I love your face. You have a great face.
Look at that. That's amazing!
Let's do a cute one. Just for the kids.
For the kids right?
Whenever I take a picture
literally my phone is like
50 of the same pictures.
Like, slightly different pose.
Luda, do you take a lot of selfies?
No. I really don't.
No selfies?
I'm not a selfie type of guy.